you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hey everybody welcome back
to GameSpot's co-op stage here at e3
2016 we're live on the floor there's a
bunch of people wandering around and a
lot more standing in line for zelda so
we got a fun little segment for you
right now we're going to be ranking our
best and worse things of e3 and as
always we have our wonderful white bulbs
because that's how we do with props you
know we we spend a lot of money on our
high budget so joining us we have Danny
and Craig reports just and just a few
minutes ago yeah just to get bought them
last night just a few hours ago ahead
and chief ed from chiefess gamers here
what's up matinee oh of course man it's
always good especially now that you're
back over in the state yeah there we go
oh you get your own applause Hills watch
collapse so alright cool so pretty
simple and that's that I'm just gonna
ask you and you're gonna give me your
three best and three worst well but
we're gonna go one at a time so right
now what is one of the best things about
III 2016 so far press conferences stuff
on the floor I saw a guy get carried out
by security earlier that was crazy
that's kind of a fun moment really yeah
dude he was screaming that people were
killing him and then like that dragged
him out and then a helicopter came by it
was crazy they got us yeah I'm not
making myself making out on my best
moments so far v3 the guy getting
dragged out that happened but I didn't
happen yeah alright cool so first up
chibi was one of your best moments of e3
2016 so all right I was very very
impressed with the sony presser micah
not impressed with my handwriting but i
thought because the content was great
but as just an entertainment show to sit
there and watch it was great they had an
orchestra they had great looking games
that were coming out one after another
they didn't have guys on stage showing
stats right about how many consoles that
they sold because they could have
totally done that yeah these they have
they're in they're capable of bragging
they're winning they didn't do that they
just showed games and it was a great
show they did a really good job wait to
be mentioned earlier they did a good job
of letting their games do their talking
from they
and it was it was just fun to watch it
was fun to sit there and be like oh this
is going yeah I made this reference
earlier you go to a movie and you see
the preview sometimes the previews of
the best part right and there was no
movie per se it was just a bunch of
previews and that was awesome got a lot
of excitement and the orchestra was just
like I just a little touch of class like
I love that and the shout out to that
projection system that they had what
that was putting different environments
on the stage where really where Kojima
sorta missed his cue and the lights of
God and then without a head of it it was
a I think that there will be a time
where Kojima looks back and he's like oh
I went too fast look nobody ever gets
that entrance ever like unless you're
Magneto right like that's it no magneto
would just hug her in because that he
does it's crazy but alright cool what do
you got what's your can't draw the quake
logo I don't think that's the quake 1
pitch fork I can't it works yeah if I
cable man I did that then I would find
to be the quake three logo I think there
you go wait champions I mean it's kind
of an unknown quantity it for a hot
second I thought it was a MOBA and I was
freaking out it's not they've said it's
the first person shooter coming to pc
only so that makes me feel better i mean
i don't know exactly what's gonna be
maybe it's you know specific heroes or
champions with like specific you know
move sash my team based maybe the team
based thing didn't work forty marina
that was gonna bahamas and we do live in
a world with like you know lawbreakers
doing its thing and overwatch is
obviously like kicking ass and those
games are awesome i mean they're
basically action quake which would you
be upset if it was class-based mmm the
Devils in the detail with this kind of
stuff I won't I really quick that right
yeah yeah and the camera pointed out is
you're totally right and the counter
pointed out is that like the Unreal
Tournament alpha been playing for about
a year yeah that is literally exactly
what I would have wanted it is unreal
tournament in like twenty sixteen right
let's put it and it's good but it's not
great it's nothing to write home about
it's not like I'm playing overwatch I'm
like oh my god so right in a way I kind
of like post due mid I trust you do
you're weird quake don't let me tell
let's hopefully it's okay I feel like a
lot of the games that are like being
rebooted or brought back right they're
kind of like it kind of like
just really really dislike taking a
flyer on something they're like well
right people like quake is not a big
franchise anymore right nothing there no
I mean you could go to kid on the street
and be like you played quake it'll be
like what yeah they have no idea right
the younger demo does not understand
what quake was and is right so if they
take it back in it and it totally you
know if it goes doom and then it becomes
cool to play again you got the older
audience who played it and the younger
audience you bring him in all a sudden
you revitalizing franchise at a fairly
minimal expense because you know it's
not like you're having to come up with
entirely new characters and war and all
that stuff anyway so one thing that did
detract from quake was that terrible
aftershock pun that shortly follow oh
god yeah even he's like if you'd forgive
the pun yeah the aftershock never say if
you forgive the pun and say sometimes
cheaper stuff yeah exactly all right
Craig what was one of your best moments
of e3 for me this a game that I heard
about last year they talked about it but
for me it's all about cioffi okay see it
thieves a game by rare uh not not old
days got you in the wave back up I love
the way that they presented sea of
thieves as far as they said hey here's a
bunch of people with zero instruction
they're gonna play the game and they're
gonna have an awesome time and look I I
know from experience would you make
youtube video will you make it a video
in that style YouTube style video where
you're just cutting and slicing however
you want you can make anything look
amazing Briah they made it look amazing
and they made me want to play it because
just a simple idea of saying yeah these
people have never touched this game
before they were given no instructions I
love everything about that and yeah one
of them looked like nick when he was
fine another one look like some of their
guys look like bizarro versions of
people at our office we had like bizarro
Nick Missouri Austin Harper like it but
it gets me excited because I just
looking at how this is and the idea of
like teamwork and being pirates and how
many do having to have some sort of
teamwork elements and to destroy the
other ships that's really cool and I
like the idea of pirates drowning in a
bloody mess of after getting hit by
cannonballs until then I'm fun it's like
a fun pirate playground is kind of what
it looks it's like what you said earlier
it's sid meier's pirates it's like that
with wood Bates
hopefully you know it'll be as much
about exploration as it is about combat
all of these people have amazing teeth
by the way oh yeah for pirates yeah yeah
for pirates especially look at that guy
like that guy he's got some he's got
some chompers you can eat an apple in
like two bikes oh you want two people
you go pirate dentist and he's the best
ok well the art style is really good to
it appeals to young people and I think
adult it's kind of cartoony but you know
I like it alright cool CD I would not
expect that one from you Craig actually
I'm stoked I I legitimately like pirate
games are cool I like iron play
uncharted 4 so no I haven't even charged
in between a yr 0 [ __ ] back on for
mmm yep delicious do you like donkey
islands I like games with pirates all
getting a pirate and charcoal black
black you never play that never play
black flag but pirate raid you know for
somebody who knows came to pirates haha
danny i like the idea being a pirate I
like yeah we're good our segment let's
just talk about pirates no no it's like
pirate thing uh-huh yeah look let's just
follow me on to that ah and pan pan hook
Rufio sorry right sorry oh I'm at sites
yeah what are you hyped about all right
we might number two best yeah it's
called duty infinite warfare nice okay
this is an infinity symbol with a smiley
face aleutian I saw a guy with that
should be their logo yeah [ __ ] the
macula sexy ah this looks amazing it's
it's basically no man's sky combined
with call of duty and detonator and I
mean everything that you want in a
shooting game think about what you just
said I know you ever think you don't
drive a call of duty like that I did not
think I would ever be flying a spaceship
in kohls via jumping out of that
spaceship and then shooting people and
then getting back in the spaceship and
flying away and there's also robots that
you get to shoot also yeah I'd so who
doesn't like shooting robots especially
what if there's pirates space pirates
Greg oh yeah I love samus aran she's a
space pirate I'm just saying that's a
good thing I know what she's a space
bounty hunter she fights
whatever replies whatever it's all but
yeah you know the thing about thing
about infinite warfare and I mentioned
this to you earlier and there's this on
Twitter but it have they shown how they
had they just felt like this a new game
nobody's gonna know what it is and they
didn't put a title to it they'll have
been the talk of the show as they just
said this is a game coming soon they
didn't even give it a title all right
Greg like that's that's it that's the
game I want you're in space with grab
grappling hooks and moving around from
place to place shooting guys oh yeah
sounds great but then that I call of
duty and then all the haters came out uh
my duty a guy on facebook literally I
mention that this guy goes your harm is
that right I looked at it I said I don't
like this anymore it owns like dude
that's the problem you're so close
minded you loved it until five seconds
prior that's amazing that's why they
chose the name at the end of course yeah
yeah well no idea about really what the
content of the game is right i mean
right that a flying portion could be one
mission for we do we judge figuratively
good job yeah it's a fun job there's
never a repercussion anyway cuz i
decided not to draw in anybody's really
I've already drawn that's all wonderful
I'm more excited about your picture than
I am for the game this is Norman Reedus
on his demon baby nightmare situation
and the five people in the what the [ __ ]
is this game called again that's the
trip I think yeah Kojima's madness
Kojima's is Scrooge McDuck but yeah
climbing through gold a large a weird
name and landings yet stranding really
likes to take words and you know where
they don't belong metal gear solid well
you know the thing about it is is they
said I saw an interview with Kojima and
he's like here's the thing the game's
not coming for a long time yeah so like
it could it will probably be 2018 2019
before we see this game right so it's
like your dog is hungry and instead of
like giving him a little bit of food you
just like what's up shiny in front of my
guy say yeah yeah this is gonna like
there's got enough can we like go back
in like two years time when we ever it
is we see gameplay of this game and
re-watch this [ __ ] and see if there's
anything to do with it whatsoever you'll
be amazed if you play as
one of the five five things on the rise
and not as not as your guy you know that
there's a rail shooter you're just like
yeah yeah Phileas Kojima he just follows
Norman Reedus around in his weird life I
mean but the Rays I'm happy about this
is that this only happens with hideo
kojima and sony this only happens when
you've got this author who makes who
makes games that are almost good beside
the story that is in them like the Sun
is almost like incomprehensible yeah but
it's in a really good game so I'm like
forced to play it and so I think it's
wonderful that this not nonsense gets to
happen the other I can't wait to see
more of it literally you could just be
walking around picking up baby baby
entire game that's the thing is like
they showed it off and you know people
were like you know that looks pretty
good it was right yeah what's happening
crying cuz a baby's dead this dead fish
in people are like like what the call of
duty people must feel like to be like we
gave them spaceships and insulators and
we've got Norman Reedus sort of [ __ ]
ipod child these are like yeah yeah I
know a child i'm fighting a problem i'm
assuming the pinna is a weapon on a
chain then you just cradle or block
leganes do they need add that a dead
rising it definitely needs a grappling
hook that's the only thing it's missing
right now right yeah like a baby or
throw a tease reg uh did mine is very
simple I've had zero interest in this
franchise up until now I'm talking about
the bearded one talking about God oh
yeah and war all right here's the thing
i literally this game i play god of war
one I was like okay I get it mmm i get
it and and for me i'm not a huge like
getting get involved in the story guy
right like it's like I get it you know
Greek mythology and fun and he's up
against the ba ba ba yeah but this one I
when I saw this trailer I was like okay
this is different this excites me I'm
fighting this giant guy on on on ice and
I'm and he know what he's got fire and
he's gonna like and my son's over there
and he's gonna shoot me with an arrow
that sounds really cool but it seems to
play nothing like the old carnivore game
yes that's like yes right and then that
great that sounds of me that seems to be
the thing and if you're gonna reboot
something don't you want to change it
while keeping it the same yeah that's
exactly what they've done it's familiar
but different
and you know just the idea of as a dad
right right the idea that it was
terrible a parent is great on so i need
to grow a dad beard let me let me just
say this let me just say this if I got
shot by an arrow I would slap the [ __ ]
out of that all right both you you don't
know heavens it was that kind of scary
calm rage you know like where he gets
hit he's just like uh he's like wait
later you know it goes back in since I
don't say sorry just be getting better
retweet away parenting but Kratos
getting shot with an arrow is like you
stepping on a letter yeah yeah yeah yeah
I've gotta do the other thing did I hate
those freaking Lego yeah don't get the
chains out long haha that's like a dark
turn but uh yeah I got a new gotta wear
looks pretty cool we'll see what happens
so I'm actually gonna cut you guys off
from your best we're gonna talk about
the worst cuz okay up time and that's
what people really care about on the
internet let's be honest all right so uh
not sure yet something already right
yeah just like Troy your masterpiece
real going to worse yeah we're gonna
move on to work okay unless you guys
want to just fire him off real fast I'm
ready Zelda looked alright Zelda Zelda
that Zelda cool i was i logged in kendo
okay referring to the IT guys really
knows what I have to rush to give him a
time limit for everyone it'll be great
the presidents and presence in general
is kind of disappointing they did the
best they could with it because they
were able to generate a giant line by
showing one game and by having a really
long demo yeah but it's a little sad
okay so starting out the worst of III
with Nintendo wow that's alright that's
an unpopular opinion your honest people
waiting with that man ein all day it's
not worth it apparently can tweet at him
at cheap ed to tell him how much did you
think that Zelda look great when you
watch the yeah yeah oh yeah we talked
about it like the visuals we're great I
think I was like a I think it looks like
a moving watercolor painting which that
to me is very cool like it isn't that to
disguise the fact that it doesn't have a
lot of one hundred percent absolutely it
worked yeah he's on board this little
easier agendas always done so well as
they disguise their limits and
especially when you look at anything on
the weed you know like you look at or
the wii u they've done a really good job
of making their games i almost have a
timeless art style to them right
you look at Mario Mario was not advanced
like the idea that the reason why old
school mario games hold up to today is
they still look like Mario today right
and he's a very simple look it's pretty
it's colorful and that's what Nintendo
does yeah and I like it also you might
feel a little bit better when we start
seeing footage of like it running on NX
right yeah yeah what if it wanted 4k oh
I don't even know what that means don't
worry tender doesn't know what that
means either they'll get with 4k after
everybody's already done it for a while
oh alright she's your mutt yeah I i
fluffed this drawing earlier today so
hopefully I've done a better that you
dr. squirt being fresh it's the xbox
Scorpio and he's wearing it scorpion but
he's wearing a suit and he's also got a
red ring on it he looks like a Russian
soldier he's got that raw scorpion okay
I've learned to be looking hook coming
out of his hands I matter you guys whys
he looking up yeah we're building C beer
that's not even a spear he's just
looking up he's not even know I ball
gets your beer the horrible drawing okay
words over here yeah we're on opposite
sides of this argument gay cool Scorpio
they'd say that they came out with a
sizzle reel but a bunch of developers
basically saying it's amazing it's gonna
lose power it's gonna be able to run for
de que era plum it's gonna be six
teraflop sort of [ __ ] that means it's
going to be able to like run virtual
reality with like no limits I'm like the
pc is right now that cost two grand
cannot do that they cannot run for gay
games at 60 frames out of the some of
them sure but like a lot of them they
can Linda 1080 is just released and they
apparently can do right it's just I so
like for them to talk about this and
then i'll actually show any
specifications to not show what chief
use it's not get into the nitty-gritty
it's not even like we're it's 18 months
out and i think they now said something
and there they have to solve that
problem yeah it was cool to see it but i
think there's a lot of smoke and mirrors
with this one it also and i think it's
gonna be Craig's point to is it just why
would you announce a slim console and
then immediately be like but don't worry
in like a year forget about that so like
I just think like totally put themselves
cragger okay no I don't get that I don't
understand the idea of that I Danny I
know your your thought process is it's a
bridge the xbox one it s is a bridge why
do we need a bridge like the Xbox one
with it just came
three years ago again it is one of those
4k streaming yeah I've never seen
anything in 4k ever in my entire life
except for when I go to bestbuy and they
show me IDK TVs right I have it in my
living room oh yeah you do huh okay I'll
tell you guys know not as are you
getting it not a big selling point to
have 4k streaming I mean it'll highly
compressed 4k in the living room you
still really need to be very close to
the television and most people don't
have are not sitting you know seven feet
away from their signify Vinci CD or it's
really closer you're supposed to be
closer so it's not a really big step for
it's not a really big selling point I
don't think yeah yeah I think you know
the question I have is those who don't
own an xbox one all right will they hey
let's see I actually think I didn't put
this in a poll but we actually give a
pope for this would you buy it not buy
it or just buy both right and I think
the answer is they'll they'll wait till
the Scorpio guy me that's not gonna do
if there's a finish line out there why
why would you you know stop halfway
through I ran into numerous people since
that was announced just talking about
stuff like Oh what did you think of
whatever and every single person that I
talk to you surprised converse was like
I always got I got really amped about
this and I was gonna buy it and then
they told me about the Scorpios right
now I'm not going to they're like why
would they do that I wonder if there's
some sort cuz i saw when i worked in
like gamestop and stuff I saw you always
be surprised by the people who was who
bought the new like the new iterations
of stuff ever knows it was those it was
those folks who were like who eventually
get into every generation but always a
couple years late and they just need
that extra little push to get them in
there's like there's a library games now
it's two hundred ninety nine dollars and
then all the smaller smaller and it
looks nice and that ends up being so I
wonder there's probably some like really
clever sales people who know that
exactly what they're doing yelping you
can rally around from a marketing
perspective as well well you can't rally
ran like oh here's the same thing we
released to not be exactly all right
what's your next worst GV on next works
okay I'm gonna sort of normal a little
point we don't like to use the word
worst sorry oh no it's disappointing
okay what is this 15 I fit into this
category okay so i have x box one cry
baby cry hahaha people who are up
that now about this xbox play anywhere
program I said that pcs pc gamers or
have access to these games now I don't
understand why Xbox one console owners
would be upset by that I I doesn't take
anything away from them right well I
thought it takes away their exclusivity
is what they feel like that's so silly I
know no i get it and that's that was a
big thing to and you know I think
Microsoft did a really good job kind of
disguising that little slip because they
were like everything they weren't just
gonna be like they didn't say the
phrases every game that we're doing is
also going to be on PC because I'm
worried about pissing people up so they
just casually snuck it in at the end
they're all just like and this is all's
gonna be able to stand it across plays
with each other that's it we came right
after every single time but cross
splints it walks by yeah in Crosswhite
so great how can you be upset by that I
know it just means like it's say you're
an xbox one owner and if you if you if
you have a PC it's only good if you
don't what's it hurting exactly it's a
pride thing it's silly yeah hmm all
right what do you got daddy can you
figure that one out roll oh yeah I know
exactly what though no that's that's uh
that's all brother on the final day yeah
yeah there we go we always get one bad
mo every year don't know that maybe that
worst may have been all the reject one
of worse III demos FF right it was
almost broken work and working demo of
everybody so he could not roll under now
he was trying to like blink past this
massive colossal SARM and there's a
thing right so we run this life stage
here every year we usually do like two
of them sometimes and the one thing that
changes every year is that once you get
a lot of people in with all over their
bluetooth and all their Wi-Fi stuff then
wireless controllers seem to have a
nightmare and I wonder if that's what
happened whereas like it was working
fine before they started and then the
mineral as people came in like the
latency just totally screwed you really
giving him the benefit of the doubt baby
that's very easy by the demos Final
Fantasy 15 he can't be bad at the game
oh but it was just it was maybe he felt
the pressure of all the people watching
yeah it seemed like they wrapped it up
early then as well because of it so it's
disappointing cuz that game has got
those so many aspects that look
interesting like the road trip stuff and
they showed a boss fight that but was
busted as I know it's just rolling
rolling rolling getting slapped out and
then I love when it was over he's just
like they give you things Matthew that
was great this is like
kill you when we get back it's like a
robot for him yeah poor Matthew I think
that was his name unless we never forget
Final Fantasy 15 all right Craig what's
your recovered or a second most
disappointing this is probably gonna be
the last one yep here it is this is a
franchise that I played quite a bit
simply just called gears of more of the
same right get it there you go all right
I don't get it actually if you just go
to tears or more I'm here's any matters
more all right yeah the office same
might have been so I didn't know I got
it yeah there you go I got it sometimes
you gotta explain things okay I get it
you got a chainsaw what was the initial
draw of gears of war at Lansford
carranza in character models also big
character model yeah don't like we've
been there we've seen it it's still a
game that is I love coloring video games
gears is tremendous at having a brown
environment it's it's the everything
they showed looked like a gears game
before it nothing made me go oh yeah I
really want to play that that's a that's
a system over say it was assistant mover
three games ago him but as soon as i
played through gears of war one i did a
co-op it was fun i played gears of war
two i played the intro and said I've
played this before and I put it down
haven't touched it since alright nothing
I saw in Gears of War for maybe want to
come back to it at all yeah and the demo
that they showed is really drab looking
you know everybody it's really muddy an
older car and I think that's been a
consensus especially with all the games
right now that are just kind of
reimagining themselves that we've been
totally so yeah you got final fantasy
doing this crazy that's what hurts it
more than anything and unfortunately
I've got to catch you up uh hello that
was our best and worst of e3 I hope you
guys enjoyed it from gamespot's co-op
stays live from e3 2016 haha i just did
the current of the Frog things pretty
good night yeah that's how we do
everything alright guys so stay tuned
we'll be back in just a few and we are
going to play a fun game called buy rent
or burn so see you in a second oh thanks
GP thank you
you